let's move on to Donald Trump and the
trials of Donald Trump or in particular
we want to discuss one trial uh one of
Donald Trump's many trials I should say
uh on Friday he was ordered to pay more
than $80 million to egene Carol uh who's
a writer who alleges that more than 25
years ago um she can't be too specific
about the date she can't remember but
Trump uh sexually assaulted her uh and
he was found to be liable for rape uh a
few months ago and then last week found
to be liable again uh for defaming her
uh and this is a civil it's important to
point out this is a civil case not a
criminal case uh but nonetheless an80
million payment is Big Money even for
someone like Donald Trump I'm joined by
the wonderful lion Sher our much loved
columnist who has written a great piece
about this again uh column always good
I'm sorry I'm being overly flattered but
there we go um uh uh about this this
week um Lionel the headline of your
pieces can Donald Trump get a fair trial
uh it's a good headline but it does seem
to be a bit to one of those questions to
which the answer is
no oh almost always when uh when
headlines are posed as a question the
answer is obvious half the time I don't
read the article yeah it's like no next
um
I mean the irony is that uh Americans
have always prided themselves on this
notion that all are equal before the law
and what we usually mean by that is that
people in positions of privilege who are
wealthy who are influential are not
going to be treated as if they're
special they're not going to get any
concessions they have to meet the same
standards as everyone else and this is
one of those odd situations where I
think being someone who is uh
influential and uh is a a celebrity as
well as you know
uh at this point in the
polls advantage to become president of
the United States this this
unusual uh appearance of privilege is
actually a disadvantage for Trump and it
means that uh he can't be tried like
just anyone else and there's there's no
way that anybody in any of these trials
jurors or or judges don't have an
opinion about him to begin with you
you're not going to be able to find a
jury anywhere that that approaches
Donald Trump in a state of Innocence yes
well we better be careful here in case
we have to pay EEG Carol 8 million know
we should we but I think I mean let's be
clear that we don't know we can't prove
or disprove uh the allegation and
neither can she because there's there's
no evidence uh for it Beyond her word
and the testimony of two of her friends
um who Their Own Story got some scrutiny
during the trial um but what we can say
is that uh she um is is a a writer of
sort of uh a lot of sort of erotic
fantasy she wrote a uh hunteress
Thompson a book about Hunter Thompson in
which she sort of fantasized about being
raped by hunteress Thompson um she
didn't uh uh I think it's confirmed now
that she in fact I know it's confirmed
now that she had the idea to uh Sue
Donald Trump for rape uh after going to
a a resistance party resistance being
the sort of anti-trump uh movement she
went to a resistance party in New York
and George Conway uh the husband of
Kellan Conway who is very anti-trump uh
suggested it to her um it's not u a sort
of normal uh rape uh story um and it's
not uh even a normal historic rape
allegation it's a very peculiar one and
EEG Carol I think she's quite um
amusingly eccentric by the looks of her
but she is it's not your it's not your
kind of your classic story is
it well first off of course it's too old
um she waited a very long time to bring
these charges and we should note that um
even in in civil terms uh this statute
of limitations had run out and this case
was only possible because in the wake of
Meo New York passed a law that made it
possible for created a one-time
window uh for sexual abuse victims to um
bring their charges to court in defiance
of the statute of limitations having run
out uh and I question that law I mean
it's a
classic uh you
know legislation passed in a state of
social hysteria speaking to the urgency
of the immediate moment and that's a
formula for bad legislation I think that
uh statute of limitations on
sexual abuse charges are a good idea
because uh memories fade and and
evidence becomes non-existent this is a
very good example there is no uh
material evidence for this ever having
occurred um aside from her having
confided in a couple of her friends uh
after after it it occurred so uh that's
why it would never have stood up in
Criminal Court where you have to have uh
an
overwhelming uh certainty of guilt
whereas in civil court it only has to be
Beyond 50% likely that this person is
guilty um which is much looser and also
further makes this the size of this
award absurd I think it's worth asking
the question as to whether or not uh
egene Carroll would ever have brought
this suit if it weren't Donald Trump
this is another example of it's he's not
he's not being protected because of his
position he's being attacked because of
his position de yes and so you think it
the the combination of it being Trump
and this uh new New York law adult
survivors law um makes it impossible but
I mean the adult survivors law could
actually be problematic for anyone
really because it depends on a on a
jury um and in New York uh you're quite
likely to get a new a jury that would be
full of people who believe who think
that believe all women uh is is a
reasonable
position um I think of all places Trump
or someone like him does not have a
chance in New York state I mean it's
it's chalk full of Democrats yes and uh
and it's run by an attorney general who
has pretty much uh come to power uh on a
pledge to get Donald
Trump yes which seems vaguely illegal to
me I just I don't know how that's
possible that you can um and then you
can run on a platform of going after a
particular citizen in in the judicial
system and I you know this is part of a
larger uh picture because of course
there are those four
other um trials and the 91 charges that
we keep hearing
about and you know it smells bad I uh I
I agree with the what has become a
mainstream view uh on on the right of
Center that this is not the way even if
you want to this is not the way to take
down Donald Trump you should he should
be deated he should be defeated in The
Ballot Box and not not in the courts and
and I think because Democrats are not
liking the look of the polls they're
getting more and more motivated to go
after Trump in the courts uh including
by taking him off the belt it all
together for example in in Colorado and
Maine and I just think this whole
approach is wrongheaded uh it looks
genuinely anti-democratic from people
who never shut up about democracy yes
and not only is it failing to stop trump
it could actually help him win of course
yeah and it you know it feeds all the
paranoia on the right that the Democrats
are out to get Trump by any means
possible and I think they're right
yeah could you give us a little bit of
an insight as an American who knows
Britain uh very well um on the ways
different ways in which Americans and
Brits think about the law because it's
often seemed to me that Americans accept
at some level that their legal system is
more politicized because it is um and
then it means that when Brits look at
legal American stories we assume that
the law has a sort of Integrity that
perhaps Americans don't it is that a
fair thing to
say maybe but I think that there's a
politicized element in the UK also
especially now that you have a supreme
court uh the decisions around brexit
were highly political and uh maybe that
was new to a a lot of Britain uh that
the the courts have their own opinions I
think to completely trust any justice
system as unpolitical is naive because
it's run by people and people have
opinions and and and they have certain
outcomes that they
prefer uh going in so there's there's
there's a political element to it anyway
and the all that neutrality is a
conceit
so and you know obviously with the
situation of the Supreme Court in the US
uh it because Justices are appointed by
a particular president with a particular
Viewpoint and party uh so the court is
is eternally divided between liberals
and
conservatives uh yeah from a distance it
it looks bad but I don't think it's that
different in the UK and lastly I know
LEL I know it's very rude to ask people
how they're going to vote and I I won't
do that directly but certainly four
years ago you supported Joe Biden over
Donald Trump uh I get you said the
beginning you're not you're not a trump
St we we I get that but do you really
think uh four more years of Joe Biden
would be uh uh better than four more
years of Donald Trump I think four more
years of Joe Biden will will or would be
a catastrophe I there is no good outcome
for this election unless something
changes the number of people who are
convinced that at least the Democrats
are going to replace Biden at the last
minute is is very high and I don't know
what I I can't tell the difference
between uh sound intuition in this case
and wishful thinking because people are
so desperate that Biden not run again
and especially with kamla Harris as his
vice president and as I understand the
reason reasoning uh on the Democratic
side it's oh you know you you can't uh
push Biden into stepping down because
then there would be this obligation to
take kamla Harris who would be roundly
defeated against dog catcher I mean
anybody she she would lose I guarantee
you to
anybody um because you know
she's part black and part Indian and
she's the first female vice president
and you can't insult these groups of
people I think that's a false I think
that's a false assumption I think she's
so widely disliked that that includes a
huge number of black people and Indian
people and women so uh so that that's
that's a false assumption but that's
that's the that's the logic According to
which you know iess the Heavies and the
Democratic party have have not leaned
very hard on him to to reconsider but uh
the
this if it goes ahead Trump and Biden
there is no way I'm I'm going to be
happy at the end of election night I
mean I'm going to be depressed
regardless of what happens and it's just
a competition of of which future strikes
me as slightly more horrific and
honestly I think it's a dead heat well
uh I hope we'll have uh many more
updates from you as that depressing
evening approaches uh thank you very
much
[Music]
LEL